>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
CONDEMNING THE CONTINUING
ASSAULTS ON SYRIAN REBELS
OUTSIDE DAMASCUS.
MORE KILLING TODAY.
WITH THE DEATH TOLL FOR THE WEEK
NOW ECLIPSING 400.
ON THE STORY FROM OUR MIDDLE
EAST NEWSROOM.
>> RELENTLESSLY DAY AND NIGHT
AND THE SYRIAN CIVIL WAR IS AT
ITS PEEK.
AT LEAST 426 PEOPLE INCLUDING 98
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN KILLED SINCE
SUNDAY AFTER THE SYRIAN
GOVERNMENT BACKED BY IRAN AND
RUSSIA LAUNCHED A NEW OFFENSIVE.
>> WHAT RUSSIA AND WHAT IRAN AND
WHAT SYRIA HAVE DONE RECENTLY IS
A HUMANITARIAN DISGRACE.
>> THE 400,000 RESIDENTS HAVE
BEEN STARVED AND BOMBS HAVE
STRUCK MORE THAN A DOZEN
HOSPITALS.
>> TRYING TO END THE SITUATION
IN SYRIA BY FORCE AND THIS IS
THE ONLY LANGUAGE THAT HE KNOWS.
>> TWO DAYS AGO, THE U.N.
SECURITY COUNCIL CALLED FOR A
RESOLUTION AIMING AT A 30-DAY
CEASE-FIRE TO ALLOW FOR
EVACUATIONS OF THE SICK AND THE
CONVOYS OF AID TO GET IN.
BUT RUSSIA HAS REPEATEDLY
BLOCKED AND DELAYED.
NOW, ARGUING OVER THE WORDING.
IT LIES TO THE EAST OF DAMASCUS
AND WHERE THE SARIN GAS ATTACK
TOOK PLACE IN 2013.
THAT WAS MEANT TO BE THE RED
LINE FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP  --
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> NOW, FAMILIES ARE DYING
AGAIN.
>> I HAVE NOWHERE TO BURY MY
SON.
RUSSIAN PLANES HAVE DESTROYED
EVERYTHING.
>> PRESIDENT ASSAD'S CAMPAIGN
HAS BEEN CELEBRATED IN SOME
PARTS OF SYRIA AND HE INSISTS
HE'S ATTACKING TERRORISTS.
BUT AS BOMBS FLATTEN THE WHOLE
AREA, FEW AROUND THE WORLD
BELIEVE HIM.
FRANCE'S AMBASSADOR HAS POINTED
THE FINGER AT THE U.N. SAYING
FAILURE TO ACT NOW WOULD BE THE